[Music]
hi there welcome to the point this week
coming to you from Japan town in San
Francisco why are we here well today I
want to talk to you about a little game
called Shenmue a rather large
Kickstarter and the changing face of
video game funding Shenmue
it's that Dreamcast game where you drive
a forklift search for your father's
murderer and have awkward conversations
with dozens of strangers about where the
sailors hang out hey we're the de
sailors hangout
sailors created by arcade game designer
Yu Suzuki Shenmue was almost on the
complete opposite side of the game
design spectrum a sprawling digital city
one where you were free to explore when
were seemingly anything was possible
Sega announced the Shenmue would in fact
be debuting a brand new genre called
free or full reactive I entertainment
which basically meant that anything that
existed in the game world you could pick
up and interact so I could pick up with
this mic pack I could go talk to that
guy and his daughter I could pick up
some of these empty cigarette butts I
won't be doing that and in the world of
2015 it doesn't seem that crazy and
we've got open-world games we've got
crazy large-scale adventure games I get
a noir but back in the late 90s this
idea of three was nothing short of
revolutionary I wasn't the cheap game to
make either costing somewhere in the
realm of sixty million dollars though
some of that funding poured onto its
sequel which came out two years later on
Dreamcast in Japan and Europe but only
on xbox in North America since those
days the world of open-world gaming has
evolved into something altogether
different but that hasn't stopped fans
of the series pining for the
continuation of you Suzuki's Interactive
Odyssey so the game was around the world
Otis for the longest time seemed like an
impossible feat Sega owned the rights to
Shenmue and the previous decade had
hardly been kind to the Tokyo based
company and in this risk-averse world of
triple-a game development even the most
passionate fans can't just resurrect
their favorite series or can they this
week on the point we asked how a 10 year
old game came back from the dead why
Sony picked it up and why we all paid
for it
[Music]
and three I can say Shenmue 3 is real in
what could very likely go down is the
most memorable III moment of all time
Shenmue was the final strike of Sony's
impressive three-punch combination of
reviving fan favorite games first we saw
the return of Last Guardian a game in
development limbo for half a decade that
many assumed dead dead a full remaster
of Final Fantasy 7 a project long
desired by fans of the 1997 RPG for the
live audience in the millions watching
these streams at home these were
incredible moments it seemed for a time
for a couple of minutes that anything
could be possible but even then in that
moment of magic the most optimistic of
gamer would struggle to believe that we
could also see the return of Shenmue
that was of course until the petals
[Music]
no no no oh
at e3 2015 Sony announced a Kickstarter
to help you Suzuki create his next
Shenmue game but how did this happen
Haider the game with countless
developing obstacles from a developer
who hadn't worked on a full console game
in over a decade with an unproven market
on a property owned by Sega appear on
Sony stage and as a Kickstarter why were
they even asking for our money to figure
all of this out we decided to travel
south to San Mateo and talk to geo Corsi
about building lists and funding
Japanese video games how did you keep it
a secret for so long oh dude
keeping Shenmue a secret was so yeah it
was really tough what was the code name
it had to okay I had to one was Ebisu
which is a district in Tokyo okay and
the second was ramen because it's my
favorite food I was working on it so we
called it ramen I can and only very few
like honestly a handful of people within
Sony knew what those code words mean so
you know during weekly meetings I'd be
given an update on ramen or ABC would
people be like like don't worry about it
just this is little thing we're working
on and you know having meetings with Yu
Suzuki and Adam boys at GDC III and TGS
that's tough almost two years ago in
August 30th 2013 geo course he had of
Sony's third-party production asked the
internet for help
Sony were building a list a list of
games the fans would like to see return
hashtag building the list would continue
throughout the year taking in
suggestions in via Twitter and all the
while geo and his team were counting the
replies gamers impress around the globe
wanted to know what was on this list
what was in the top ten and who was on
top time to spill the beans Geo we
started that collating all these games
and right off the bat Shenmue was really
was a number one
right off the bat yeah people ask you
know what was number one and always play
it vague and stuff but now that it's
been announced
Shenmue was number one like from day one
so you know I was kind of like wow this
this if you haven't heard of Shimoda
yearís lina this is this is crazy that
was August of 2013 in packs after
Christmas so January 2014 Adam calls me
in the office it's like you'll never
believe who I just got off the phone the
Shenmue guys they want to meet at GDC
Emily I think yeah Yu Suzuki wants to
meet and discuss Shenmue 3 and I'm like
this is crazy like we have to keep this
uber quiet yeah because if it starts
getting out it's all over you know and
he's like yeah absolutely so GDC comes
around we met it's some clandestine
meeting I love that 40th floor of some
hotel and it was just you know all of us
and you know Adam and him are talking
I'm just sitting there like a wide-eyed
idiot and we just started talking about
you know all the different ideas of how
we could do this and is there a way that
we could help out oh just everything
design ideas funding ideas what none you
know
Shenmue hasn't been around for well over
a decade yes people have somewhat
forgotten about it and at the time you
know while it was semi successful it was
a niche title yes it had a very loud you
know fan base but are those fans still
around today or is it just a few on
Twitter who keep hammering me saying we
want this game we want this game so when
you Sookie suggested Kickstarter and we
were like okay let's see you know this
this has got some legs here let's see if
there are truly our fans who want this
game or if it's all just smoke and
mirrors and you know it started just
ended and I think the fans have spoken
that they want this game Shenmue 3
reached its two million dollar goal in
one day but the original game cost
around sixty million dollars so headed
Sonjia new Suzuki come to a two million
dollar ask the amount of money it
received the Yu Suzuki said it'd be
great about 10 million because then I'd
be able to make a key open-world game on
my dreams it landed around six point
five which is yeah some people say it's
not a lot of money right let's make a
game it's a lot of money we you know I
time we were like okay what what could
we ask for because you know you Suzuki
was like let's ask for X and we're like
done Kickstarter has never done that
before yes we have to be we have to be
realistic in what we're asking for and
we all agreed that two would be a great
number because are there more than you
know two million dollars worth of fans
out there yeah at the time you didn't
know if you have no idea it's a totally
unknown thing so we said two million
which at the time was still a very big
ask on Kickstarter but when that blew
through that within 24 hours or 48 hours
or whatever it was we were just like
okay no they the the ask is real they
really want this game and I mean
throughout the thing you Suzuki was
showing us design ideas and and it is a
layered design idea like you know
obviously when he went out and said I
would love 10 million dollars like
that's his dream absolutely
but he has a design that scales to what
is possible and the technology today and
the it is much better than it was when
he originally mentioned you can do a lot
more with today's technology than you
could back in the day so I think fans
are gonna be really really excited with
with the project when it comes out it's
really exciting for PC players to be
able to play it it's really exciting for
PlayStation 4 on this be able to play
and I own and play both systems you know
at the time it's it's it's exciting to
see it coming to multiple platforms
obviously people are associating this
game with Sony because it was on the
Sony stage right do you guys have any
exclusivity rights on this at all or is
it just a partnership of sort of
mutually benefits you both cuz you're
associating with each other we're
talking through all that sort of stuff
right now we we just wanted to get
focused on the Kickstarter get the
announced out of the way get the
Kickstarter out of the way and see what
happens now it's a you know it's a long
road produc
and we'll see what happens Sony took a
risk and it happened to pay off fans
came out of the woodwork but the next
interesting part in this tale is how a
game that we've seen hardly any gameplay
for whatsoever raises six point three
million dollars who is donating all this
cash why first of all there are the
well-publicized whales individuals who
contribute large amounts of funds
because they can simply afford it
gamers from wealthy backgrounds
self-made businesspeople and the odd
superfan who sees it as their one big
treat speaking of fan sender are those
who feel nostalgia for the project this
is why on Kickstarter we tend to see a
lot of throw box Double Fine adventure
ukulele bloodstains shadowrun returns we
want to play these new games but we
often think about these projects as tip
jars giving back to creators who made
something that had an effect on us in
our young life then there's FOMO fear of
missing out a term often used in
investor circles people who see everyone
else funding a project to see rewards
being snapped up and just want to be
part of the story I fell into that
category I added about 25 bucks to the
Kickstarter and I've never owned a copy
of Shenmue why I guess I just wanted to
be part of the moment but there's a much
more powerful force at play when it
comes to the Shenmue 3 Kickstarter one
that I'm all too familiar with this is
the first thing I ever kick started back
in 2012 it's a book event a history of
sensible software chances are you've
never heard of them but sensible
software are the most popular developer
of my childhood when I first got a
platform a GameSpot I put together a
feature about their history the games
they made and their unfortunate demise
once games went 3d in September 2012
I've gave $40 to this book campaign not
because I particularly wanted to read a
book about sensible software I've
actually never read a page of it but
because my favorite game company
sensible software died in the 90s their
story ended on with their story ended a
little part of my history ended too
nostalgia is strong but the stile juh
for something that feels like it's gone
forever is even stronger it's clear to
anyone mad that Shenmue 3 would never
have been made if it wasn't for this
Kickstarter it took a hardware giant
working closely with a creator who
managed to somehow get permission from
the rights holder to set up a high
reaching Kickstarter for even the
positive
ability of Shenmue 3 to be made if it
failed Shenmue would have been dead
forever that that would have been it
Shenmue 3 was dragged across the line by
almost goodwill alone so for for you
guys in terms of like you know what is
what it what is it in it for Sony I
guess you'll get a great game that the
fans want on your platform is it is it
mostly about like having that goodwill
with gamers because presumably this is a
game it's probably not going to make a
lot of money and if I'm not gonna make
you guys a lot of money necessarily
right no it is about goodwill for the
gamers and for just bringing great
content to the planet the combined group
third party production we're gonna offer
production support milestone reviews
helping you know you Suzuki this team
through development our partner Lions
team will help with marketing and PR
we're getting the demos and the trailers
out when the time comes having some time
to show the game at some of the events
helping them release the game and
getting it through all the submissions
and the TRC's for both the physical
individual Shenmue raised all that cash
because Shenmue fans didn't want the
dream to die for good and general gamers
chipped in because the story of Shenmue
this weird revolutionary oddity in
gaming's history was something that
we've collectively carried with us for
over a decade like half-life episode 3
in the Last Guardian through rumors news
stories and the hope that if these lost
games could make a return then perhaps
our favorite games could also make a
return something time continues to
trundle forward whether we like it or
not and the sad reality is that as it
does this we leave things in the past
memories that make us modern experiences
that made us who we are
Shenmue 3 was funded successfully for
the same reason that so many of these
projects in Kickstarter are because most
of us simply aren't ready to leave the
past behind
you